[Música]
economía en directo América de France 24
y me acompaña Daniela landón Daniela Qué
bueno saludarla vamos a hablar de
petróleo porque las recientes decisiones
de los países exportadores han agitado
el debate político en occidente Hola
Raúl pues Comencemos por saber qué es la
opepa más creada en 1960 Esta es una
organización conformada por 13 países
liderados por Arabia Saudita más 11
aliados encabezados por Rusia ambos los
mayores exportadores de petróleo del
mundo ahora de 100 millones de barriles
que consume el planeta al día 43
millones vienen de estos países y de ese
total unos 20 millones casi la mitad los
producen Rusia y Arabia Saudita de ahí
la importancia del anuncio de esta
semana de que recortará en dos millones
de barriles su oferta diaria de crudo
esto quiere decir el 2% de la demanda
mundial Julio César Vera experto del
mercado nos contó porque la OPEP es tan
clave en estos momentos
es muy complejo cuando un grupo de
países controlan un porcentaje tan
importante la oferta porque no estamos
hablando del 5 del día 19 del 43% de la
oferta mundial de petróleo que puede
haber alguien que lo contrarreste yo
creo que fue una decisión de los países
productores del mundo de poder tener un
control sobre el mercado Y pues
obviamente aquellos tienen unas reglas
donde funcionan articuladamente no es
que uno mande sobre otro no son unas
reglas de articulación y donde pues
obviamente hacen unos anuncios que
principalmente los dominan dos países no
que es en el por el lado de la Pep
Arabia es el que toma las decisiones y
por el otro lado Rusia no de los que lo
que se llama el más es Rusia Pero quien
controla realmente la capacidad de
producción en las capacidades decisiones
en Sarabia que es el que tiene realmente
un excelente capacidad puede subir y
bajar fácilmente los demás se apoyan
hacen ajustes pero es muy poco lo que
aportan realmente
ahora como estas decisiones dan y
afectan en nuestro bolsillo Bueno pues
por la regla económica los precios
internacionales del petróleo son la base
de lo que terminan siendo los precios de
la gasolina y en consecuencia del
transporte también de los alimentos de
la canasta familiar en general hace tres
meses un barril costaba 120 dólares hoy
ronda los 90 dólares pero para que haya
aumento de los precios no solamente debe
haber una oferta más limitada sino que
se necesita de una demanda fuerte y
nosotros como consumidores También
tenemos esa potestad de reducirla como
no explica nuestro invitado
podría ser digamos en general la demanda
sería hacer un uso racional de de
hidrocarburos como tal de reducir su
consumo lo cual ayudaría en cierta
medida al nivelar las condiciones Pero
se ve muy complejo en un escenario de
reactivación pues pandemia que la
demanda global del mundo pueda
racionalizarse Por supuesto que estos
efectos de precios altos tienen un
efecto natural directo en la reducción
propia demanda en algunas regiones y
creo que el invierno próximo que se
avisó ahora seguramente será un
escenario para calibrar que tanto la
demanda podrá reducirse por efecto de
tener unos precios tan altos de los
energéticos como tal pero en el
escenario el corto plazo no se avisó
ahora que por el lado de la oferta a
diferencia de lo que puede hacer Estados
Unidos o por el lado de la demanda Y
sobre todo países como China India Japón
Estados Unidos que son los mayores
consumidores y los mayores demandantes
de petróleo pudieran tomar medidas de
corto plazo que permitieran reducir la
demanda y nivelar la caída en oferta
como tal Dani Y en todo este pleito hay
un jugador clave Bueno ya lo decía Julio
César Vera Se trata de Arabia Saudita en
el fondo todo esto es una batalla
política Por qué Porque la Casa Blanca
viene rogando para que ese Grifo en
lugar de cerrarse se abra para tener
mejores precios de los combustibles pero
su relación con Rusia está debilitada y
Moscú tiene una gran influencia en la
OPEP más
no estamos poniendo en peligro los
mercados energéticos estamos brindando
seguridad y estabilidad a los mercados
todo tiene un precio la seguridad
energética también tiene un precio Pues
el presidente estuvo en riada A mediados
de este año y todos pensaban que iba a
estrechar los lazos con este importante
miembro de la OPEP pero parece que no
fue así el viaje no fue esencialmente
por petróleo este viaje fue sobre el
medio oriente y sobre Israel en la
racionalización de posiciones pero la
decisión de la OPEP es decepcionante y
nos dice que hay problemas
pues el secretario de estado Anthony
blingen desde Lima fue un poco más allá
y aseguró que se están revisando varias
opciones con respecto a la relación con
Arabia Saudita agregó que lo que están
es consultando de cerca con el congreso
allí los demócratas pidieron reducir
drásticamente las ventas militares a
este país
pues Dani como siempre Gracias por toda
la información económica nosotros nos
vamos